[Music]
we're continuing our coverage this
morning of the 100th anniversary of the
tulsa massacre
hundreds of black people were killed or
injured by a white mob
during a two-day rampage which began on
this day
in 1921. more than 30 blocks
of black-owned homes and businesses were
destroyed
the violence was covered up for decades
now the greenwood art project is
supporting a technology non-profit to
remember the businesses lost
with a modern day twist omar via franco
joins us again
from tulsa omar what an honor for you to
be down there good morning
good morning it absolutely is and there
was an estimated 200 businesses that
were part of black wall street who were
destroyed
during that massacre but today there are
some tulsa students who are developing a
modern way to honor that legacy
but also learn some important tech
skills
100 years after it was burned to the
ground the legacy of black wall street
will continue
this time digitally thanks to tech
industry veteran and tulsa native
mikel vaughn hey welcome welcome and his
students to urban coders guild
which teaches stem skills to kids from
underserved communities
this was one of those crazy ideas that
come to you at 2am
there was a whole community business
that existed and so the idea is that if
those businesses
existed in 2021 they would most likely
have a website they will most likely
have a mobile app
and we're teaching kids to make websites
and we're teaching kids to make mobile
apps and so it made sense that we do
this
this is historicblackwallstreet.com
a collection of web pages for businesses
including the dreamland theater
the hotel alexander and the red wing
cafe
noted at the time for its swell electric
piano
you're not only giving them a computer
science lesson you're also giving them a
history lesson
absolutely my kids are learning you know
the web technologies the mobile
technologies but we partnered with tulsa
community college they're
doing the research and then there was
another group of people from tulsa
community college that were doing
graphic design and logos and so this is
a collaborative effort
very much in the spirit of greenwood
very much in the spirit of black wall
street
what do you want people who see this to
get out of it
i want them to understand the importance
of our history brother and sister isaac
and raven arterberry
are two of 40 students in the urban
coders guild
isaac researched vernon amy church the
only building that survived the massacre
what is it like creating something
digitally
but also physically seeing a piece of it
i think it's interesting that we're able
to make it more permanent in a way
because physically it could be destroyed
and all that but when you make it
digital
it basically lasts forever which i think
is really cool you can't burn that down
no you can't brenda nails alfred
a descendant of several survivors of the
massacre
said she appreciates the work of
students like the arterberries
it speaks volumes to the legacies that
made black wall street and you all will
carry on that legacy
for your young coders do you think this
is connecting them
to a to a past that a lot of people
didn't talk about
it's connecting them to a past for sure
but we also want to focus on connecting
them to a future
that maybe they need to even imagine a
future working in
in tech maybe being a coder is this the
next chapter
of black wall street i hope so i would
want it to be
so far there are only a handful of
businesses in the directory but they
plan on adding more
in the coming months and this is not
only just a tech lesson for these kids
tarika michelle and anthony
this is also a history lesson because a
lot of them are just learning
about what happened here 100 years ago
yeah
it was a history that was just wiped out
i mean in many cases just not talked
about or ignored
literally this is such a great project
because it actually
it make it those kids are making this
current by doing what they're doing
they're they're
they are they're learning history but
they're also making it come around and
as
as that one uh said uh
you know you can't burn this down it
it's it's and it also
it brings it back into the conversation
and if those kids carry it forward this
story will not fade away again
and that's the key no it won't